que jean jacques fontaine journaliste et
spécialiste du brésil
bonsoir jean jacques fontaine merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france on l'a vu
le président bolson arrow est un
farouche opposant au confinement il
critique notamment la politique de
certains gouverneurs qui ont imposé le
confinement dans des états est ce qu'ils
n'en fait pas trop ailleurs bolton arrow
il est bien seul au monde à avoir une
position aussi strict alors ils ont fait
beaucoup depuis le début du confinement
brésil qui a été décrétée par certains
états à partir du 15 mars
il a 34 fois de suite pendant les
week-ends pris les bonnes foules sans
autre protection pour bien marquer que
pour lui cette épidémie n'était qu'une
petite grippe et que ça n'allait pas le
toucher
donc effectivement il multiplie les
provocations et derrière cette
multiplication d'époque provocation il y
assure tous ont besoin et son envie de
s'appuyer sur ses partisans les quelques
30 % de brésiliens qui sont derrière lui
mais surtout les églises évangéliques un
certain nombre de membres du milieu
entrepreneurial et des fractions très
d'extrême droite de l'opinion publique
est ce que c'est une balade c'est une
posture politique ou est ce que c'est
vraiment selon lui le seul moyen de de
ne pas mettre l'économie à l'arrêt on
avait d'ailleurs que son ministre de la
santé avait encore démissionné c'est le
deuxième alors c'est le deuxième en un
mois donc le deuxième démission du
ministre de la santé
c'est le deuxième médecin ministre de la
santé qui s'en va à titre temporaire
intérimaire paulson araud a nommé un
général spécialiste non pas de la
médecine mais
deux des infrastructures et de la
logistique comme ministre intérimaire en
fait beau le maroc n'a pas de politique
ni par rapport à l'ouverture économique
ni par rapport à la vie que sanitaire
aujourd'hui ils pilotent à vue en
fonction de ce que lui dit ses
conseillers mais les sondages par
rapport à sa propre popularité est en
fait son sa perspective c'est les
élections présidentielles de 2022 où il
veut se fair et sûrs et rien de plus
alors on a vu en il donne aussi des
informations et des vidéos qui sont
diffusées ou où il dit que finalement ce
n'est pas là la manne unités de du virus
qui est en cause mais la fragilité des
personnes
en gros ce qui prévaut a ajouté ce n'est
pas le pouvoir d' agression du virus
mais justement la fragilité des gens qui
mourront
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que les
plus faibles finalement peuvent mourir
et pas les autres
alors bon délire ça ils s'appuient sur
ce qu'il appelle le confinement
verticale c'est à dire mettre en
confinement seulement les personnes à
risque et les personnes les plus âgées
les personnes qui ont déjà des maladies
qui les prédisposent au virus et c'est
rare mais en fait derrière tout ça il ya
le l'idée que tant pis hall est mort il
ne dit pas aussi clairement mais ça veut
dire ça ce qui est important c'est qu'on
passe par là dessus et que le coni
repartent et alors dont l'effet qu'elles
sont les plus affectées par cette
épidémie
c'est pas nécessairement ces personnages
dont il parle mais ce sont les plus
pauvres qui vivent notamment farinas qui
sont sains qui sont dans l'impossibilité
de garder les distances sociales
vu l'étroitesse des logements des rues
et c'est rare vu le fait qu'ils ont plus
de boulot non plus et
ce sont en même temps ces personnes là
qui tombe malade et qui vu la faiblesse
du système de santé publique ne peut pas
se faire soigner et il dit aussi que le
chômage la faim et la misère seront
l'avenir de ceux qui soutiennent la
tyrannie de l'isolément total
ça veut dire que ces personnes faibles
auront double peine c'est reste confiné
ça veut surtout dire qu'il n'a pas
compris que si l'épidémie se répandrait
et si on arrêtait pendaison prenait pas
de mesures sanitaires pour empêcher son
développement
c'est toute l'économie qui va être mise
à bas parce que le problème c'est pas
tellement d'arrêter un moment dans le
fonctionnement de l'économie pour
essayer de faire face à la pandémie
mais effectivement de mettre toute la
population dans une situation où elle ne
peut plus consommer ou elle ne peut plus
faire face à la situation et où
effectivement l'économie risque de venir
à bah non pas à cause des mesures de
confinement quand l'épidémie mais à
cause de l'épidémie albin donc rayan
wolson arrow suis également finalement
ce que fait donald trump dans son pays
on le voit un donald trump qui veut à
tout prix relancer l'économie du pays et
les américains qui manifeste pour le
droit de travailler c'est le cas
également au brésil est ce que certains
manifestent pour pouvoir retourner au
travail effectivement ball sonar ou suit
son mentor donald trump en poussant un
peu même la caricature donald trump
d'une manière un peu tropicale il a
derrière lui un certain nombre de
personnes qui le soutiennent notamment
les églises évangéliques qui d'ailleurs
ont obtenu du président que les églises
se considérer comme des commerces ou des
activités prioritaires donc les églises
évangéliques sont réouvertes pour les
cultes et olé pour les cérémonies
malgré les insanités cela représente on
se souvient que 1,8 des principales des
principaux foyers d'épidémie en france a
été un culte évangélique à mulhouse
juste pour rappel mais il y a
effectivement derrière bolton 1re un
certain nombre de personnes qui
soutiennent
et puis il y à cette mesure tout à fait
démagogique qui l'a prise de fournir 2
reposé une salle subsides de 600 dh pour
trois mois pour les plus pauvres qui
fait que dans les favelas où les gens
ont perdu leur travail mais il ya une
remontée sa popularité parce que on se
dira mais il nous paye quelque chose je
défie transmag nous ce que ce qu'a fait
aussi la france merci beaucoup jean
jacques fontaine d'avoir répondu à nos
questions sur rt france